Сполучені Штати Америки роблять для України
набагато більше, ніж Європейський Союз.
Український президент Володимир Зеленський
погодився з таким твердженням президента США Дональда Трампа
під час їхньої скандальної телефонної розмови,
що набула міжнародного розголосу.
Зеленський також погодився, що США
більше допомагає санкціями проти Росії, ніж ЄС.
"Хочу сказати, що ми багато робимо для України.
Ми вкладаємо багато зусиль і багато часу.
Набагато більше, ніж країни Європи. І вони мали б
надавати вам більшу допомогу, ніж вони роблять зараз.
Німеччина майже нічого для вас не робить.
Все, що вони роблять, - балачки..."
"Європейський Союз має бути нашим найбільшим партнером.
Але технічно США набагато більший партнер, ніж ЄС.
І я дуже вдячний Вам за це, за те, що Штати роблять багато для України.
Набагато більше, ніж Європейський Союз, особливо
коли ми говоримо про санкції проти Російської Федерації".
Уже наступного дня після оприлюднення
стенограми телефонної розмови президентів України та США
низка німецьких ЗМІ вийшли з матеріалами, які розвінчують такі заяви.
Вони посилаються на дані німецького уряду, який
із 2014 року надав Україні допомоги
на загальну суму 1,4 мільярда євро.
Зокрема лише на співпрацю в галузі розвитку
за ці роки Україні надали понад 544 мільйони євро,
ще 110 мільйонів євро гуманітарної допомоги,
фінансовий кредит на 500 мільйонів євро
та 25 мільйонів євро на заходи щодо стабілізації
безпекової та правової ситуації в країні, зокрема
моніторинг конфлікту на Донбасі. А також
200 мільйонів євро, виплачені Києву через ЄС.
У Брюсселі, своєю чергою, також заявили
про рекордну підтримку, яка була надана Україні.
Зокрема, з 2014 року Євросоюз і європейські
фінансові інститути спрямували
понад 15 мільярдів євро у вигляді грантів і позик.
Про це йдеться в заяві речниці ЄС
із закордонних справ та політики безпеки Маї Косьянчич.
Гроші пішли на просування реформ у таких сферах,
як децентралізація, державне управління,
боротьба з корупцією та економічний розвиток.
Нині Брюссель реалізовує в Україні 500 різних проектів.
Тим часом США у 2019 році
збільшили допомогу Україні до 700 мільйонів доларів.
Повідомляється, що загалом за часи незалежності України
США надали Києву понад сім мільярдів доларів допомоги.
Окрім військово-технічної підтримки
та допомоги в безпековій сфері, Вашингтон також
підтримує Київ у відбудові, енергетиці, охороні здоров’я тощо.
За даними Організації економічного співробітництва та розвитку,
першу сходинку за обсягами виділеної допомоги Україні
з 2014 року посідає ЄС, США - другу.
На третьому місці - Німеччина.
У 2016-2017 роках, за підрахунками ОЕСР,
допомога ЄС була удвічі більшою, ніж допомога США.
Що ж до санкцій, Європейський Cоюз
після анексії Криму у 2014 році і початку
бойових дій на Донбасі запровадив, а згодом
розширив і щопівроку продовжує санкції, пов’язані
з порушенням територіальної цілісності, суверенітету й незалежності України.
Зокрема, це секторальні санкції, які діють щодо Росії,
санкції за анексію Криму та Севастополя, а також
персональні санкції, які охоплюють 170 фізичних
і 44 юридичних осіб. Паралельно такі
санкції щодо Росії вводили і Сполучені Штати.
І Брюссель, і Вашингтон також майже паралельно
запровадили додаткові санкції проти російських компаній
за будівництво Керченського моста та
проти російських громадян через захоплення
українських кораблів у Чорному морі.
Лише в питанні будівництва газопроводу "Північний потік-2"
європейські й американські лідери не зійшлися в позиціях.
На відміну від ЄС, США виступають
категорично проти  "Північного потоку-2" і вже
підготували пакет санкцій проти компаній,
задіяних у реалізації цього проекту.
Німеччина і ЄС виділяють не менше
фінансової допомоги Україні, ніж США.
Щодо санкцій, то з 2014 року і Брюссель, і Вашингтон
паралельно вводили і персональні, і секторальні санкції щодо Росії,
а також санкції за будівництво Керченського моста
та захоплення українських кораблів у Чорному морі.
Лише в питанні будівництва "Північного потоку-2"
США, на відміну від ЄС, виступили проти цього проекту.